let's go next to our caller from the 805
area code who is calling today from 805
that will be me David
my name is Gabriel hey Gabriel and I'm
calling hi I'm calling from Canoga Park
I am an independent I have a Twitter I
just started a Twitter account not long
ago called Gabriel with a B as in Victor
messenger
Aram so I wouldn't talk today about the
news but just a little bit about myself
I'm from Mexico I came here when I was
17 and so first I only have any
documents for seven years
even though my mother was the US citizen
when I became a resident alien and then
I became a US citizen in 2001 so but I
want to talk about the news I see that
we emphasize too much Donald Trump
maybe we should be emphasizing a little
bit more you know Bernie Sanders at
least I know that we need to talk about
Donald Trump and all the things like
he's been doing wrong you know but maybe
we should talk also more about Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders I voted for
Bernie Sanders the last time you know
and I was really upset that Hillary
Clinton stole the nomination with a DNC
from the you know from Bernie Sanders
you know so I don't know if and the
reason I say this is because I know
you've ever seen that movie the secret I
have not
were they talk about work okay so they
talk about where they we put the energy
you know what we talk about is worth all
the energy goes to so it seems like
we're putting too much energy into
Donald Trump I know that we have to
criticize so he's been doing wrong as I
said before but I think that we also
need to emphasize more what Bernie
Sanders wants to do and Alexandria Casa
Cortez mm-hmm and at least a bit poor
and I also happen to like to see khabar
a lot myself
please think of art reason being like
yeah I know that you know she hasn't
done that great I don't know why I think
that she
greater following hmm but going back to
the news my question is were these that
where he comes to Fox News all the
damage they do because even though there
are neither ones throwing the stone they
are the ones given the stones and I'm
referring also to the megan phelps
interview that you had with her which
was great and so i'm saying a lot of
things i'm sorry but yeah what was your
question today specifically though so my
question is you think that we should ban
certain social media and news outlets
when they have such a hateful discourse
that really basically no i think when
you because in order to do that you need
to establish someone who will do the
banning and then any time that you do
that it becomes subject to the whims of
the presidential desires it becomes
subject to the whims of whoever is in
the White House at the time and in
general I am for more speech as long as
it is not criminal and so we need to
criticize Fox News we need to criticize
outlets that are problematic there are
certain things of course that that would
be against the law but no I I don't
think we need to start banning social
media platforms or channels as as a
matter of principle no okay and my
second last question is so well I guess
it's a comment I really like what Megan
Phelps said during the interview which
is the way to reach people on the other
side I considered myself by the way was
maybe a progressive conservative okay
and so what she said and you said also
is reaching the people not so much with
facts but maybe with you know as human
beings real emotions what do you think
about that to be able to convert them
yeah I've been talking about that for
years every time I speak to you know a
former white nationalist or whoever it
is it is empathy and human connections
that either prevent them from getting
into those ideologies or or that get
them out so I could not
three more with what Megan said about
that awesome thank you so much all right
very good appreciate the phone call
great to hear from you